our main story tonight concerns school
for some it's the place to make lifelong
friends and enjoy first crushes while
for others now I'm not naming names it's
not it's different specifically we're
going to talk about homeschooling during
the pandemic many parents were suddenly
forced to do it and while some struggled
others like this family absolutely
thrived a b c d e f g h i j k a l m o p
q r s t u v w x y and z now you know
your
ABC that is clearly excellent but it's
also it is also a pretty mean way to
make other parents look like total
because that is significantly better
than anything I did with my kids during
the pandemic it was much less singing
certified alphabet bangers are much more
hiding in the closet praying they would
not find me also quick shout out to the
baby on the counter living her best life
she has no idea what's going on but yet
there she is in the center of it all
like Mariah Carey on a New Year's
broadcast now now that family like many
eventually sent their kids back to
school but for some homeschooling isn't
just a pandemic era necessity it's a way
of life and you may have heard a
stereotype of homeschoolers being
Christian conservatives who object to
what kids learn in public school
environments and I admit those people do
exist
take this man who offers this pretty
shaky rationalization for pulling his
kid out of school I think the type of
content on what they're teaching about
sex or anal sex that my third grade
daughter should not be in a classroom
where a teacher or someone else is
teaching her about that and that was
your experience in school I thre through
friends in other spots that had been
kids at those ages cuz mine was only in
first grade when we pulled them well
that sounds like total although
I guess I do basically agree with him
there things that are definitely not
happening should continue not to happen
but the truth is the homeschooling
Community is much broader than just
right-wing parents afraid of
hypothetical third grade Lube
demonstrations by one estimate there are
now around 2 million children being
homeschooled in this country and parents
can choose that for all sorts of reasons
maybe their kids have social or health
problems or disabilities that aren't
being accommodated maybe they families
with legitimate fears about school
safety or who are in the military and
move around a lot and there's also a
growing number of black parents opting
to Hom School due to whitewash
curriculums and zero tolerance policies
in schools that disproportionately
criminalize their kids at an early age
so there are lots of reasons to do it
and the fact is for some kids getting to
be homeschooled can be genuinely
transformative at 15 Victoria asked her
mom Bernita to take her out of Detroit
schools she says she was being bullied
relentlessly for her appearance and it
didn't seem like her administrators
cared it made me not want to ask
questions you know or not want to ask
specific questions because I'm like am I
like they going to call me dumb when you
transitioned to homeschooling how did
you start to feel about yourself um I
felt more confident it was just like a
kind of like a sunshine like the clouds
opening a little bit that's great that
is very nice and I know that's not
something you usually hear me say after
a clip on this show it's usually a
variation of that's horrible that's
heartbreaking or shut the up you
Baby lawn DS so frankly this this
is a welcome change of pace the point is
the ceiling of how good homeschooling
can be is admittedly very high but the
flaw of how bad it can get is basically
non-existent because to an extent that
you may not realize in many parts of the
country homeschooling is essentially
unregulated which can result in enormous
damage so given that tonight let's take
a look at homeschooling and let's start
with the fact there is a lot that we
don't know about homeschooled kids from
exactly how many there are to what they
are learning when I said there are
around two million of them the reason
that's an estimate is that depending on
the state homeschool families might not
have to report what they are doing at
all in these 26 States parents simply
have to file a notice once a year with
officials to let them know that they are
homeschooling their child in these 13
they only have to file a notice once
with no requirement to check in ever
again and in the remaining 11 they don't
have to notify by anyone at all and when
it comes to the education itself filing
a notice is typically where supervision
stops as in Most states there is no
oversight and no evaluation by anyone of
the academic program and of students
progress and homeschooling Advocates
will tell you that that is not a concern
and the parents will simply come up with
all sorts of innovative ways to teach
their kids here is one parent
enthusiastically explaining how he
taught his kids science I can't tell you
how many times um you know in my home in
our kitchen table we've dissected you
know sheep eyeballs or frogs uh kitchen
kitchens are great labs for this kind of
thing where did somebody where did
somebody get a sheep
eyeball well John you can just Google
sheep eyeball for homeschoolers lot of
people absolutely okay first are
kitchens the best lab for this kind of
thing I think probably labs are the best
lab for this kind of thing I'm just like
maybe don't go dissecting sheep eyeballs
in the same place where you cut olives
for salad also do not Google sheep
eyeballs despite what that man just said
I did it and I'm not even going to show
you the result un blurred because it is
too nauseating suffice to say it looks
like what would happen if an oyster had
a
butthole and while that man was clearly
willing to go to impressive lengths for
atome science lessons not everyone has
the time or the resources to do to
develop a curriculum from scratch that
is why there are big publishers who
offer materials specifically tailored to
homeschoolers and much of that market is
dominated by these three Christian
textbook Publishers who promise learning
through a Biblical filter and look it is
absolutely a parents right to educate
their child with religion if they so
choose but the quality of some of these
books can be troubling for instance one
current ABCA history book says that the
beginning of the 20th century witnessed
a cultural breakdown that threatened to
destroy the very roots of Western
Civilization the cause of this
dissolution was an idea or philosophy
known as liberalism meanwhile a workbook
from AC celebrates the confederate
general Robert E le as a devoted
Christian who practiced his Christianity
in all his dealings with others and a
science book from Bob Jones University
claims that biblical and scientific
evidence tends to support the idea that
men and dinosaurs existed at the same
time and if you're wondering what that
would look like AC actually had a
workbook featuring this rendering
implying that not only only did men and
dinosaurs exist at the same time but
they were totally cool with each other
hey Hank great tucked in shirt do you
see that dinosaur over there sure do Bob
love those jeans by the way should we
run no way these dinos are chill let's
just keep whacking these leaves with
that one sword knife that you
brought but while all of that is pretty
troubling the truth is in many states
the rules and oversight can be so LAX
parents don't ultimately have to teach
their kids anything at all just watch as
this former homeschool student breaks
down her daily schedule this is my
actual list of assignments we've got the
date at the top I would have been 12
first we've got classical music which
was just turning on classical music in
the morning so that everyone could hear
it we've got Bible listening we've got
handwriting and math that's fairly
normal we've got memorizing the Bible
we've got memorizing poetry uh the
Poetry was mostly hymns we've got
exercise that's good it was is usually
just walking around the block um and
then the whole entire rest of the
list is chores and cleaning
tasks it's true most of her lessons just
involve chores and just look at that
list that is a lot of cleaning demands
who was her parent this guy I mean don't
get me wrong he's an absolute zad would
will and I'll take seconds but as hot as
he makes doing CHS seem it's not an
adequate alternative to education is it
although I will say even that is a
preferable alternative to the single
worst homeschool curriculum that we
found whose creators excitedly promoted
it on a podcast we are so deeply
invested into making sure that that
child becomes a
wonderful
Nazi and homeschooling we're going to
get that done well that is terrifying
you never want to hear a mother lovingly
utter the sentence my kids are wonderful
Nazi outside of maybe if they're
praising their son's performan as Ral in
The Sound of Music and even then just
say wonderful Rolph what's wrong with
you that woman and her husband actually
launched their own online community
dissident homeschool in 2021 after she
had a quote rough time finding Nazi
approved School material for her
homeschool children and you know what
good that probably shouldn't be an easy
Google in fact if you search for that it
should probably auto correct to did you
mean how do I take myself to
jail at one point distant homeschool had
nearly 2500 subscribers and included
ideas like handwriting exercises
consisting of writing out quotes from
Adolf Hitler which I think we can all
agree is just appalling handwriting
exercises that is just cruel they should
be working on their keyboard skills
through game like Mavis Beacon teaches
the final solution although not that
don't actually do that that is awful the
channel also posted tips ensuring that
their parents were in full compliance
with the law so that the state wouldn't
interfere but as you have already seen
in Most states they don't have much to
worry about there because when it comes
to homeschooling basically anything goes
so how the is that the case well in
large part it's thanks to a very
powerful homeschooling Lobby whose most
most prominent player is The Homeschool
legal defense Association or hsld da and
here is where I will concede some ground
because it grew out an environment that
was in many places overly restrictive of
homeschooling with some states and local
school districts effectively Banning it
entirely in Texas in the early 1980s
homeschooling families were actually
prosecuted but a turning point came
after several Texas families f a class
action suit against their school
districts and ultimately won and around
that same time time the hsld was formed
with the aim of expanding the rights of
homeschoolers in every state and from
the very beginning it had a strong
Evangelical conservative Outlook its
founding president and chairman Michael
Farris has referred to Public Schools as
a Godless monstrosity and here he is
back in 2004 speaking to the Christian
Coalition and describing his long-term
hopes for the Next Generation today it
is not Preposterous to recognize what's
going on the promotion of homosexuality
to promotion of other kinds of things
that you heard from Walter Jones and
you've heard many other
times is a deplorable reality that we
cannot countenance I can't wait for the
day when our young people Vanquish the
Enemy by a 5 to four vote reversing Row
versus Wade and
uh where we Vanquish the the Spectre of
same-sex marriage that's the the
standard of Victory okay there is a lot
that is hard to take In that clip that
that's his wish list that he's already
gotten half of it and that he's saying
Vanquish the enemy despite looking less
like a warrior and more like your tax
accountant's tax accountant's assistant
over the years the hsld DA has lobbied
extensively from a hard-right
perspective on issues that have nothing
to do with homeschooling opposing
everything from vaccine mandates to
same-sex marriage but it speaks to how
significant a force it is that even some
parents who are uneasy with its
political leanings feel that they have
no choice but to be members here is one
mom who started a homeschooling group to
offer an alternative to what she saw as
a whitewashed curriculum talking about
her relationship to the hsld whenever
there's a threat in any particular state
to their right to homeschool oh you will
see us come together you know it may not
we're not going to stay together but we
will band up because we all desperately
need our right to homeschool and that's
the nuanced aspect of being in The
Homeschool world the people that you
have to work with in order to maintain
what you hold dear are also the people
who Crush you it's true the hsld da have
made themselves so powerful many parents
keep working with them even if they
don't agree with everything they stand
for it's a dilemma otherwise known as
the Tom Cruz conundrum on the one hand a
billion dollars at the box office on the
other a billion-year contract to an
alien Mafia It's Tricky right It's
Tricky what's a bunch of young Hots to
do plus for what is worth the hsld da
much like Tom Cruz will probably never
die as a lobbying group it's been
astonishingly successful in four decades
its efforts have be credited with
rolling back existing laws governing
homeschooling in state after State and
the argument that it will always make
against any regulation is you're just
punishing all the parents doing things
right to address a handful who are doing
it wrong and in theory Sure but when
you've got some parents running The
Homeschool Institute of dishwashing and
others running Lil Nazis R Us it seems
maybe the Reigns have gotten a little
loose and the lack of Regulation here
has serious consequences and not just
regarding quality of education and fair
warning this is where this story gets
quite a bit darker more than two million
children are being homeschooled in the
US many of them living in states that
have little or no regulations making it
easy for abusive parents to hide behind
the system these are the faces of just
some of the homeschooled children who've
died as a result of abuse and neglect
Susanna grubs was homeschooled in
Missouri she tells us the discipline she
received was anything but gentle I think
that in a lot of ways me and my siblings
totally fell through the cracks because
I mean with my mom's disciplinary
techniques and my mom's educational look
like it's really terrible that it it has
happened and it keeps happening and
nobody wants to stop it because parental
rights are so Paramount to anything else
in this country exactly and that is
massively dangerous because deregulating
homeschooling doesn't just eliminate
safeguards against parents who are bad
teachers it also eliminates them against
parents who are bad people for all the
hsld DA's talk of parental rights it's
worth remembering Elon Musk is a parent
OJ Simpson is a parent Darth Vader is
such a parent he made it part of his
fancy name change the point is having a
child does not inherently make you
virtuous and one of the key problems
here is child welfare laws were written
before homeschooling was legal in all 50
states so they rely heavily on the
premise that a child is going to be in
school and seen by other adults as this
da explains a lot of child abuse gets
reported through our schools teachers
and school administrators are mandated
reporters so you know if a child comes
to school with bruises or emaciated that
is a very common way that it gets
reported right because the fact is
teachers serve multiple functions at
school in addition to education they
watch out for signs of abuse they
chaperone school events and they pretend
not to know why Ellie won't sit next to
Rachel Rachel won't sit next to Kelsey
Kelsey's not talking to Ethan even
though Ethan's having a joint birthday
party with Kelsey's brother Bryce who
just happens to be Rachel's boyfriend
since last period and they do all of
that while also trying to teach long
division teachers are superheroes who
should make a million dollar a year so
you can probably see the fact that it is
possible
to pull a kid out of school with no
questions asked or follow-ups allowed
could easily be exploited by abusive
parents especially as Most states don't
even screen homeschooled parents for red
flags 48 states have no background check
process for parents who choose to
homeschool in fact even if you have a
prior conviction of a crime against a
child you can homeschool them a study
done in Connecticut found that of the
380 students withdrawn in six districts
to be homeschooled
138 lived in families that were the
subject of at least one prior report of
suspected abuse or neglect and yet
despite this at every turn the hslda has
vigorously fought efforts to put any
guard rails in place here was their then
president in 2015 explaining why they
fight all regulations even ones
explicitly designed to prevent child
abuse child abuse is a parental issue
isn't it any child whether they be a non
homeschooled child or parent where they
be a homeschooled parent they can abuse
their children they have the potential
to do it so why should we for just a few
why why should we for just a few invade
all of the other innocent parents that's
prior restraint it's unconstitutional
it's unamerican are there are there some
categories of regulations around
homeschooling that you would support
that you don't think of as an invasion
or a
takeover no not any
okay it is bad enough that he's arguing
for a total lack of Regulation there but
the fact that he openly licks the
corners of his mouth before doing so
somehow makes it worse it looks like a
cat went to a zar machine and made a
wish to be Andy
Griffith the hslda views any oversight
whatsoever as an attack even offering
members a 24-hour hotline in case of a
visit from the state in fact here is the
sister of that woman you saw earlier
explaining how they would practice what
to do if Child Protective Services
showed up on their doorstep the parent
would lock the front door would call The
Homeschool legal defense Association on
the phone hand the phone out the kitchen
window and us kids were supposed to hide
in the basement we actually did drills
on this stuff folks we did drills in
case someone ever decided to check in on
our well-being holy that is dark
drills are meant for practicing what to
do to avoid getting hurt not to avoid
getting help it's why fire alarms say
pull here in case of emergency and not
snitches get
stitches and the thing is because of its
committed membership the hslda has the
power to stop any kind of oversight in
its tracks take ry's law named after an
8-year-old girl in West Virginia whose
father pulled her out of school after he
was reported for abuse she died of
neglect only a few weeks later now
eventually legislators proposed a law
that would prevent parents from
withdrawing a child from school when
there is a pending child abuse or
neglect investigation or when a parent
has been convicted of domestic violence
child abuse or neglect and it seems like
that law would be easy to get pass right
but the legislator who proposed it found
out not so much there are groups I want
to say there like this homeschool
defense fund group that came out against
Ra's law the hsda that's it and there
were quotes about how awful this bill
was and it's an attack on homeschooling
and you know they want to move the the
goalpost that's what you do in politics
but always thought maybe protecting
children you wouldn't actually go about
that right and that seems pretty
reasonable and if the hsld da thinks
trying to protect kids from being taken
out of school by people convicted of
child abuse is an attack on
homeschooling they're saying quite a bit
about what they believe homeschooling to
be if Chile's responded to a health
inspector writing their workers up for
pissing in the skillet quo with this is
an attack on everything Chile stands for
don't punish the majority of our staff
for the minority who piss and sh it in
our Presidente Margaritas you'd have
some questions about what Chile thinks
it stands for and for the record that
man's Bill never passed and that story
has been repeated in state after state
after State as one legislative Aid who
has gone up against the hsld DA has said
I've never seen a Lobby more powerful
and scary and a legislator in Arkansas
who Tangled with them says they told me
the only legislation they wanted was
what Alaska had which was nothing at a
certain point it's start to feel like
the hsld da is basically the
homeschooling equivalent of the NRA an
extremely powerful organization that
while it represents a large number of
people pursues an outermost Fringe
version of their agenda so where do we
go from here well in a perfect world
we'd make sure that homeschool kids were
both safe and actually receiving a
functional education and there are
smaller organizations like this one
pushing for those sort of changes but at
the bearest minimum we could require in
all 50 states to register a child as
homeschooled so there's at least a
record that they exist that is how low
the bar is here at the Earth's core
which I'm sure according to at least one
homeschooling textbook is somewhere
between soil and the fiery bowels of
hell but beyond that we could pass some
basic child safety protections to ensure
parents can't pull their kids out of
school to escape scrutiny for abuse a
few years ago to its credit Georgia
passed a law that requires parents who
who pull kids out of school for no
reason to send documentation within 45
days that they are homeschooling their
child or proof of attendance at another
school if they don't do that they're
subject to a follow-up from the state
and even this Republican Georgia State
Rep acknowledges that it was needed if
the people in your world that you
believe are are most protective of you
are are torturing you or abusing you
who's going to who's going to look out
for you I mean I don't you know I don't
like government intervention and a lot
of things but I don't you know the
government's the only person I know of
that can intervene in this kind of case
to to save a child yeah he's right he's
just completely right and agreeing with
a staunch Republican Georgia State Rep
wasn't something I had on my 2023 bingo
card I I've almost got a full Bingo by
the way I'm just waiting on you know who
to you know what and to be clear I share
his ambivalence about government
intervention here I understand that
involving social services and the
government in people's personal
situations poses a risk R especially to
those who aren't wealthy and who aren't
white it's not like I love the idea of
giving The State Room to poke around in
people's lives or that I think our child
protective services system is Flawless
no notes we almost definitely going to
be doing a main story on CPS one day but
it does seem like giving parents a get
out of all scrutiny free no questions
ask card just isn't the answer here
because being a parent doesn't
automatically make someone moral and
being with a parent doesn't aut atically
make a child safe and the truth is a few
extra security measures would not hurt
the many parents who homeschool their
children responsibly but they definitely
Safeguard against those who use personal
Liberty as an excuse to neglect or harm
their kids the H LDA can say all that it
wants that it doesn't support Nazis or
child abusers but the fact is the
policies that it relentlessly pushes for
allow them to thrive and basic reforms
here just shouldn't be remotely
controversial because after all
this is about child welfare this isn't
rocket science it's not even home sheep
eye dissection don't Google it by the
way I cannot emphasize that enough all
of this is just basic common
sense